[Musique]
sont des assistantes maternelles
libérales qui se regroupent pour pouvoir
se mettre ensemble et créer un projet
autour d'un lieu pour accueillir des
enfants comme quand c'était dans leur
propre maison mais je dirais autour d'un
projet comme celui-ci par exemple qui
est un projet très spécifique
[Musique]
quand des assistantes maternelles
veulent sortir de chez elle pour faire
exactement le même travail de proximité
avec les parents et bien le se regroupe
à deux ou à trois selon les locaux
possibles pour créer une MAM qui est
quelque chose de tout à fait je dirais
intermédiaire entre l'assistante
maternelle à domicile et la crèche c'est
un intermédiaire
elle risque là proximité qu'elles ont
quand elles sont assistantes maternelle
libérale c'est justement cette proximité
avec les parents et c'est ce qu'elles
veulent recréer ici puisque les parents
ne sont pas seulement des personnes qui
viennent confier leur enfant mais ces
personnes qui sont actives également à
l'intérieur de la map puisque elle nous
disait tout à l'heure que il y avait des
activités qui est faite qui était faite
justement avec les parents
la Villa investi plus de 140 000 euros
pour pouvoir mettre à disposition ce
lieu pour ces personnes et on souhaite
bien sûr en développer d'autres sur
l'ensemble de la collectivité
[Musique]